[Musique]
ans
saga poète insisté était très moderne et
réussi à faire un immense bond en une
seule génération à passer de la pauvreté
à la richesse extrême c'est un régime
politique de démocratie d'exception à la
limite de l'autoritarisme c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'état bienveillant qui est
présent dans toutes les classes et de
lettres
[Musique]
le thème central dans tous les
reportages à singapour c'est de se
projeter dans un avenir possible chez
nous au canada dans la gestion de la
pandémie dans la robotisation de la main
d'oeuvre dans la fabrication de la
viande cultivées en laboratoire et aussi
dans la gestion des matières résiduelles
gestion des déchets
les défis sont nombreux parce que les
restrictions sanitaires en raison de la
pandémie sont encore très nombreuses ici
à singapour et il ya aussi des enjeux
d'accès aux personnes à interviewer
accès à l'information dans un pays cet
état bienveillant qui est présent dans
toutes les facettes de la vie commence
[Musique]
un certain dimanche après midi je suis
allé au festival du film de singapour et
ça m'a donné l'idée pour cette rencontre
inattendue avec deux jeunes
réalisatrices une on y admire et une en
france qui présentait en première
mondiale leurs courts métrages sur les
suite au coup d'état aux mines mais
c'était une rencontre très touchante une
rencontre qui en dit beaucoup aussi sur
l'état de la situation
comme beaucoup de pays en asie singapour
depuis le début de la pandémie c'est
essentiellement coupés du reste du monde
replié sur soi en raison des mesures
sanitaires on commence à s'ouvrir au
reste du monde mais il ya peut-être
certains enseignements ou leçons à tirer
de la gestion de la pandémie en asie par
rapport à ce qu'on a eu chez nous à tout
le moins des comparaisons à faire on a
beaucoup aussi à apprendre au niveau
technologique des solutions qui sont
développées ici et on a aussi beaucoup à
apprendre des valeurs universelles pour
partage avec ces gars trop élevé ce
natif
[Musique]